hi we're back here at devoxx 2013 i'm
here with Ludo shampoo Noir from the
cloud team at Google welcome saludo you
have two sessions here at devoxx one is
on building rest api's we'll get to that
in a moment and the other one is about
with you in App Engine and there's quite
a few things that are you actually this
year so we'll get to that part as well
but but first API is obviously Google
knows a thing or two about api's we
publish a lot of them some are very
obvious to people like maybe the Maps
API if everybody's built at least one
app with the Maps API but we have a
whole slew of them and we all based this
on one common framework which we
actually make available to developers
did you want to tell us more about how
we would go about using that so we have
been adding api's to our products
forever and it's a typical problem at
Google you know Google scale I mean
designing one API it's easy to it's easy
but once you have thousand of them you
want to version them it's it's
complicated security what security etc
so maybe you have been using the API so
I mean access to maps access to your
calendar or access to gmail g+ google
plus X attracts attracts right so we are
pretty good at delivering those api's
I'm whatever clients you have you know
whether it's PHP Python Java Joe's
create the objective c you can you can
have access to those AP item and make
use of them in your client application
so what we have done with our Cloud
endpoints is although you as a developer
to expose your business logic using the
same technology and the same techniques
to generate clients right for your
business Rajee and access addressed
restful web services so if you think
that come to mind the first one is how
do you describe the API is there a way
to discover maybe the API yes so well in
its in Java okay it's based on a
nutrition so it's not really Jax
terrorize because I mean
Sarai's was only limited to the Java
platform the Cloud endpoints technology
can can be also implemented in Python on
swinging PHP or go so for java you have
to to use very simple annotations right
and from that we generate what we call a
discovery document that describes the
video the metadata but your virtual
services and this discovery document can
be used on the under for informal client
JavaScript client to to introspect
what's going on or to generate those
client libraries right so this is
something that people may be familiar
with the discovery tool if they've been
using google api so we're using the same
environment same so if you if you go I
mean yes as if you guys are documented
automatically and you have an API
Explorer tool for rural api's as well as
for your own IP I that you want to push
so the other part is security so how do
you deal with ladder it is also a big
deal at Google I think it is it's
complicated to set up client library to
use the security using oh but we do it
and if you know how to read for for
example accessing your calendar yeah
google api is for calendar you you are
using the same mechanism that we provide
for your application as well so
obviously your business OG can be fully
secure you can restrict for client IDs
for example so maybe not everybody in
the world can access your api because
you want to restrict maybe only for
android your Android application right
so we have all those layers of its
really an environment where your API
these fully managed you know n scales of
course shells because so run yeah it
runs on Google may be an interesting use
of that API and the endpoints technology
is something called a mobile backend
starter which is something that's built
on top of that and provides a fullback
and solution for mobile app okay so it
might be a bit confusing but yes I mean
the mobile seller is an example of how
you can do a backhand and expose it to a
tool to clients and the value of it is
it's basically a January back-end that
you can plug to your phone application
application and your phone application
can store data in the cloud using the
cloud datastore store which is the non
SQL data store for from google so this
glad it gives you a framework that you
can use in your Android application to
access generically resources in the
cloud so it actually works with iOS as
well it provides notifications it's
actually much more than just a demo but
it certainly exposes the API as an
endpoint APR and as a restful set of
resources to manipulate you can do it
both as a sample an example of how you
could write your your api's or use it as
it great so a lot lots of good stuff
here in endpoints let's step back a
minute here and talk about another
offering in the cloud platform which is
the compute engine side of things which
is where we're back to as opposed to the
platform fully manager environment my
phone service here we're back to
infrastructure dealing with VMs so you
read on a vm and then you spawn this VM
there's an API for that tell us a little
bit more about what computer engineer
yes the compute engine is basically the
is a frame from google so we already do
to to boot VMs in our data center arose
whether it's one vm or 10,000 VMs very
simple you you select which zone and
which zone or yeah in geography you want
to put the image the machine type and
obvious so we have a bunch of images and
you can even add your own and storage in
cloud storage and good from it so api's
again rest-based API so we provide the
web UI to create those vm or
a success or a command line 222 pretzels
vm right and then so you you pay by the
minute and you have an epi so you can
spawn a huge number of ems and shut them
down and only pay for what you use
exactly I'm the pay per minute is very
nice because you know instead of paying
if your computer processing text let's
say 15 minutes you would pay 15 minutes
for google and not an hour so if you
fail in 15 minutes it means that you
could even shard your business
processing using for vm right and and be
done in less than 15 minutes and pay
only what you have used yeah and so of
course this is infrastructure so you
have a fairly low level where you
basically ssh into in the instance and
that is like good luck you you're on
your own you have to get all attached it
to you have the power of all this you
know network as well not just bm's I
think this great value in the network
yes of course go down saying we have vm
we have persistent disk so you can store
permanently your your data in this we
have the entire networking capability so
that those VMS can communicate sexually
sometimes privately between between them
and we just recently introduced also a
load balancer so you can shop traffic
across multiple
v ends there but it still you know you
you are in charge of witnesses VMS and
managing them so fighting yeah then if
you want to have to patch them right but
then you can run anything you want and
not just so any native code any code you
have any of that you could you could run
so what if I have an application that
runs on App Engine and i love the auto
scaling i love all of the fully managed
aspect of App Engine but I have this
little piece of native code which I
inherited from which is highly optimized
I don't want to rewrite that doesn't fit
into the App Engine model can I yes have
the best of both worlds solution for
that now I mean so App Engine is a
platform as a service offering from from
google I mean that it has been there
forever in at least since 2008 it was
running your web application in the
Google Data Center so we had to have
security rules because we do not want
you to to to look at around what was
going on on on our data center but with
the vm base back-end technology we are
introducing you can run an app engine
application inside a vm running on
compute engine and what it means is
first of all it's a free manage
application type in App Engine but it's
running in a vm where you could access
it you could install whatever your
native code you want to to track
environment organize your business any
java code to shop window java process
running on those vm is not sandbox yeah
we we don't we don't care if security is
not at that level stem exact et Cie shut
down the machine will shut down yeah you
couldn't you could not do that in
engine luckily yeah so of course that's
interesting actually that is based on a
new one of the new features in App
Engine which is modules so we used to
have front and back ends and that is
kind of being so you know no to enable
App Engine apps running in vm based
runtimes we introduced the notion of an
application is a collection of modules
okay so before you could create
front-end back-end but now it's much
easier and all those modules are virgin
able okay so you have one single app
sharing the same data store faces all
the services security services xterra
but you can cut your business logic into
modules yeah and those modules will will
run in different the end like the web
front end of the accounting the email
server 11 or n modules running in the
traditional App Engine were you know
very fast startup and highly scalable
and some modules running in
incompetently so modules have this
property of being more or less scalable
or more or less more of a front-end
thing that scales up and down based on
traffic or more of a back anything you
just say oh my module will be more less
a back-end module so I will with 10 of
them and they will always be up and
running right or my module is a front
end and i will let App Engine scale the
typical way you know 10,000 of those
that's what require if my if my yeah
customer or demon is that time ok so
modules and one of those modules and
this is what you were describing can be
actually running on compute engine and
that's the the vm runtime set of things
where so you can have native code not
just job outside the sandbox you can
have I mean I have demo using PDF
generation using Java WT libraries that
you cannot use in
in the traditional app engine model and
you get access to maybe you know faster
machines and then you know more beefy
beefy machines as well if you look at
the VMS I mean the processes we were
using for for App Engine its f1 f2 with
four but very same or configuration as
opposed to a vm run times where you can
you can have 16 cores floods your memory
Miriam so yeah beefy beefy server so in
the time we have left I want to touch on
developer experience there's been a lot
of work going on in to improving the
tooling and the tooling that's of course
IDs but that's also things like maven
what people talk about Gradle as well
you want to walk us through a principal
with the introduction of modules in App
Engine we had to to help the developer
creating multiple modules right and
again in 7n the the mapping was easy to
use ear and the price archive your files
it was five so one would you would be a
war and then your entire application can
be packaged as an your fax oh so you na
between a board tooling for that for in
maven okay in Eclipse ideas well where
we we were entirely the Eclipse plugin
for for App Engine and now we are using
wtp okay so that we could rely on all
the web application development and
enterprise archive development
capabilities in Eclipse to support our
modules and recently we we are also
involved in the Gradle plug-in for App
Engine okay so we see more and more
customers asking for grotto
if you if you remember I mean the
Android ecosystem move to a grotto as a
build system yes using the Android
schedule so having having an end-to-end
story actually majority for building so
good I could actually be using Android
studio to build my android app and
actually in the same ide build the back
end as well yeah this is yeah this is
scary but you can build up engine apps
with Android features a scary either you
use maven or use bradl now and well and
we are doing a few hooks for any poll
for endpoints endpoints is supported
studio endpoints menu items in the tools
menu yeah 12 you generate those client
library that you can consume in your
Android app ethical last thing I hear
you can actually run app engine on non
google data centers with the do there
yes so we've been working with red hat
okay and right at the makers of jboss i
think right yeah i mean reddit if you
see right at i mean they're the leaders
in the Java platform yes I mean they are
the guys in innovating in the Java EE
space and what is interesting is they
wanted to add on top of the Java
platform the App Engine api's okay so
basically they wanted to take an app
engine application right as it and run
it without modification on there jboss
application and they did the name
wildfire like whatever and they did that
but we we I mean as Google we wanted to
make sure that I mean their solution is
is compatible all right so we work
together on the tck technology
compatibility okay Ike you know
everybody knows in javelin available to
just chivas so we have now joined the
project between Google and and reddit
working on this kiss again so what it
means is many of our Q engineers from
google are moving hundreds of tests that
we had internal yet
tethering app engine we are moving them
on the tub and the J both gasp are also
contributing a lot of those tests it's
you know it's a github project it's
called app engine so it's open source
with in case of an apache license and in
fact i would encourage you to to
contribute with it if you see a black in
App Engine and you can reproduce it you
submit a unit test showing the bug and
so you're because we're accepting for
request day we will see that it's
failing great so lots of new stuff in
appengine the ability to run your App
Engine apps on top of cape dwarf is the
project name of on top of jboss and
integration with compute engine for you
know then the sky becomes the limit so I
mean lots of great things great looking
forward to seeing your sessions on
parlays and I'll speak to you later
thank you very much